did you guys see any clips from rolling
loud i saw a few
okay uh what stood out
coyla ray was the one that i saw getting
tweeted about a lot that was pretty
funny okay why why
because she is performing to a deafening
silence nobody gave a [ __ ] nobody moving
there's a couple people you look at the
video like filming and [ __ ] yeah
it is dead quiet shifty started laughing
as soon as i brought it up
i've never seen anybody bomb with this
much confidence in my life
yeah i don't know i get it though like
there's there was a few performances
that like weren't great where they were
like oh yeah they kind of bombed
i heard like kodak's wasn't amazing i
heard his was great academics was like
posting about it being like they were
turnt up but like he wasn't that good
and i don't know there's just like
random things but i'm looking at them
like yeah these guys haven't performed
in years
like literally in two years some of them
got famous in the pandemic yeah never
did a live performance
and then now they're thrust on this
massive stage with thousands of people
and they're like all right go entertain
them like
performance and rapping are two very
different things yeah
that like you don't necessarily have the
intrinsic skill to like run a room of
people and control a whole stadium
just because you're able to write words
that run yeah i don't know because i
think music is such a like it's such a
movement basic you hear music you start
moving
comedy i gotta wait and hear all your
words and then there's a punch line
you said something once that said like i
think you said music is almost like a
virus like it just spreads and you can't
help it
you just get this feeling and you just
start moving to be dead silent and still
while music is going on you almost make
a conscious choice [ __ ] this person
i think that rap is actually the hardest
uh
music to perform live yeah yeah live rap
is rough
and you know what taught me that was uh
watching karaoke
watching somebody sing karaoke if you
sing beautifully you don't even have to
move like adele doesn't need to move
she just gets to stand there you don't
gotta dance you don't get like the worse
you are
singing the more you gotta need the
theatrics like brittany needs 15 backup
dancers she's doing backflips all this
other [ __ ]
adele just stands there and just
breathes
and sings and the pipes are so crazy
that you're just completely enthralled
right
um whitney another one like whitney i
guess could move but at a certain point
time it's like sweetheart just stand
right there and sing that [ __ ] we will
sit here national anthem performance yes
stood there it was amazing yeah it just
affects you it penetrates
rap doesn't do it the thing about rap
that's interesting
is actually what you're saying like yes
there is a melody and there is like a
rhythm to it and you get caught up in a
beat and a bounce
but the words mean something to the
person right like you get to live
vicariously through that person even if
you're not a gangster even if you get no
[ __ ]
like saying you get [ __ ] is dope and
you feel you want to rap with them right
so what if you don't know the lyrics to
a rapper it's toast like if you karaoke
a rap song that nobody knows in a
karaoke bar nobody's singing along with
that [ __ ]
it's absolutely useless so i think the
skill of performing to what mark was
saying
really comes in handy there if you know
how to move a crowd really know how to
do call and response
really know how to get a crowd active
and into
the small parts of the song that they do
know
the chorus or even if they don't know
the song you're just like left side when
i say this you go to the right side when
i say this
now they're engaged and that takes real
[ __ ] skill
man because rap is boring live yo
that [ __ ] is mind-numbingly boring live
like let me give you a push back on that
okay go it's boring
to watch a live performance when you're
not there
i think everybody who's there the energy
you get caught up in it yeah
yeah i watched a lot live rap sound
nothing like their track like they're
they're like screaming the [ __ ] voice
and they don't sound like
track but you're still having an amazing
time really you're having an amazing
time because everybody around you knows
the lyrics we're vibing out like this is
our song that we played alone in our
room a bunch of times
now a bunch of people i'm surrounded by
all no [ __ ] lyrics like i'm vibing
more with people in the crowd than i am
actually with the artist so i think it's
like when you're there it's
way different than like we're watching
clips of it so it's hard to really gauge
how
impactful the performance is interesting
okay you were saying
i was gonna say that that's a fair point
also if we can all agree
typically rap is the hardest to perform
live maybe it's the worst live whatever
generally speaking
that means people have accepted that and
they'll still vibe out and they'll still
rock out and have the time of their
lives so when someone goes out there and
nobody gives a [ __ ]
it's almost more of a more damning that
it's like nah
we'll [ __ ] we'll [ __ ] with a lot of bad
live music i'm not doing this
yeah that's true that is true like there
are certain songs from a band
that again if you have an amazing voice
i can tolerate yeah
wow that's fire with rap honestly it's
not even the bars because i might not
even understand what you're saying for
the first time i hear the rap especially
live it's not crisp
but it's got to be the beat yeah like
remember we were watching [ __ ] um the
baby
the baby and uh yeah yeah you didn't
know a single song prior to watching
that but
that's like the whole that's why rap is
so seductive to me because like it's
less about
necessarily what you're saying but it's
like attitude and like energy and
demeanor and like
swag obviously but but for me i was like
schoolboy q
he didn't have much swag and like it was
more just like he's kind of swaggy say
what he was kind of swaggy all right all
right
i'll be honest i was shocked at his like
his dancing ability i i was like oh wow
this guy can actually move
like he was hitting some [ __ ] and i was
like oh this is surprising
but uh but the beats were crazy dude and
maybe it's because i was high but
it was crazy talking about the beats for
weeks the beats were insane
but that's i'm taking that and then the
baby's beats weren't that good
remember i feel the audience was turning
up more for him
only you would turn them more for
somebody accused beats were
that's the greatest producer in history
the beats were crazy
it was unbelievable those beasts what
did you enjoy about the performance
the beats bro the beats were [ __ ]
insane crazy
it was it was amazing but i think they
were like at peak high
during school yeah starting to come down
for the baby yeah
whoever made this beat is the man of the
year bro
man in a year yeah yeah rap live is
great
it depends dog it needs more like jay-z
brings out the whole orchestra for a
reason because just listen what are you
talking about
you've been saying jc concert yes it's
just him and usually memphis blink on
stage nobody else
you've clearly never been what are you
talking about i've been to like five
jay-z concerts
you clearly have never seen jay-z alive
daisy travels with the whole rock nation
orchestra
it's there every single show you've
never seen there's no one jay-z lyrics
no idea what the [ __ ] you're talking
about did you go to when he was at the
barclays when he headlined those shows
clearly you did it not at the barclays
you're not a fan you saw him in like 40
40. he never goes to barclays you
wrapped one song
over like it played on the floor yeah he
only goes to the garden
did you go there for justin timberlake
who would you go there for yeah
no the black album what the tour he did
for black album
so i went to that one i went to the tour
he did for uh and
little baby and jay-z are the same to
him he doesn't even know he doesn't like
the words
yo little baby is our artist he starts
going out he's saying black out
that's our artist that's the people who
we resonate with like y'all don't really
understand i don't
understand how long ago the black ops
yeah i go i go ow
name one lyric from little baby he
couldn't name
one lyric he could name a line but he
couldn't name what rhymed
could it could
i knew that one i know more little baby
lyrics all right go where
oh we said that next no you never said
that i always said that baby little baby
a little bit
i'm from atlanta i'm from atlanta i
don't got no tattoos
i don't got tattoos i got no tattoos i'm
from atlanta
yo for real you lied about that and
you're lying about jay-z you've never
been to a jay-z
i can believe he went to the black album
tour that was the last time he probably
felt black was 15 years ago
sure i think that was it you just said
done came over
that's it done went to one tour i
honestly i think now if you would know
that jay-z travels with the roc nation
orchestra
you're so stupid
he's like known for actually being a
great performer because he controls the
stage
he [ __ ] makes eye contact at people
like he'll call somebody's
out all the way in the back what they're
wearing and [ __ ] like that it's a
[ __ ] um
rap is fire alive bro
like yeah he's actually uh he's actually
an excellent performer
he's low energy but he commands the
stage
for having low energy yeah it sounds
like his songs
yeah it's actually it's actually really
impressive but
that being said you've never been to it
live so you wouldn't know only i would
know and he does travel with the full
orchestra no he doesn't does he not
i just google it yeah you know he does
it yes he does he doesn't have google
ads
[Laughter]
saxophones trombones right yeah you
don't know it's just
that's him with the orchestra that's him
every night yeah memph bleak rock nation
orchestra
jay-z
y'all really don't know what it's like
man did you see any of the clips from
rolling loud
uh what i thought was really interesting
is like the little oozy fert
uh situation what happened so little uzi
vert uh
did uh uh roc nation said that there
weren't streaming his life
because you could watch uh rolling loud
stream right and
i think that's all game i think that's
all like building this mystique
of uzi uzi is like mystique right like
everything about him is like interesting
wait is it a 20 million diamond on his
forehead is it not
is he out here doing shows is he gonna
drop an album like does he have a
bugatti worth three million that he got
[ __ ] wrapped in some weird like anime
paint like
what is going on with this specific guy
and then you find out you know from
academics he's selling 3 000 tickets
and that's it when he does shows because
people aren't coming out for the shows
so i think everything about uzi
is building this mystique and he's a
spectacle it's a spectacle and he's a
really interesting like an engaging
guy because of it and he leans into it
is he straight yes he has a girl but he
leans into like the femme stuff at times
like you're like what the [ __ ] is going
on he'll pull up on another rapper with
his goons and like they got guns and
[ __ ]
like what what is this guy and i think
this just lends itself to the mystique i
don't think there's any rule with roc
nation like we don't stream his music i
think it's literally just let's build
misty get people talking about it and
here we are
[ __ ] talking about i thought it was a
i thought it was a money situation
really i thought he just
doesn't have like good relations with
them and so they're just like
oh [ __ ] it we're not gonna [ __ ] with you
and this is gonna hurt you by not
streaming
yeah maybe i mean there's also like
doesn't uh jay-z put on a uh
um a show what is his show born in
america or something like made in
america
made in america yeah so maybe like
i want to save my streaming thing for
made in america philly
you know uzi's from philly maybe oh yeah
that would make sense
yeah that's like a big [ __ ] deal
philly shuts down for a little bit maybe
they do like a big one and then he's one
of the headliners and
everybody goes crazy and if we starve
them out now at rolling loud
start the conversation then it'll be
even bigger that he's actually going to
be strong let's go to the school boy
cute concert that's the takeaway
[ __ ] the beats are fired just get some
headphones man it's unbelievable
i'm gonna get high no no just listen
instrumental you don't mean i say that i
mean i'll smoke cbd in that freeze pipe
because
it's my lungs otherwise hit that freeze
pipe and then put on that goddamn
school boy i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna
[ __ ] man yeah